this morning we're taking a look at life
inside the largest resettlement complex
for evacuees who fled afghanistan after
the taliban takeover it's called fort
mccoy it's an army post in wisconsin and
one of eight military bases taking part
in operation allies welcome it provides
nearly 13 000 afghans with medical care
and support to build their lives in the
united states in an exclusive interview
nancy chen spoke to one family of seven
who left their world behind and are now
starting over nancy good morning
tony good morning to you the first
evacuees arrived here nearly six weeks
ago it is one of eight military
installations across the country housing
those who have left afghanistan families
are working now to adjust to their new
lives and new realities
there is gratitude and hope for families
starting a new life and getting their
chance at achieving the american dream
it was so hard to leave our home our
country nineteen-year-old sultana amani
arrived in the u.s in late august with
her family after fleeing afghanistan
under taliban rule you never would have
wanted to leave otherwise i was happy
there but
when the tall one came we were in danger
surrounded by miles of farmland and
cornfields this is where the amani
family is starting their life in the u.s
this initiative follows through on
america's commitment to afghan personnel
who helped us about half the evacuees
housed here are children who take
english classes
craft art projects and kick soccer balls
however there is sadness for what they
left behind sultana's father muhammad
naimamani
i worked for 40 years
and seeing everything goes to waste i
seeing the kids seeing the woman going
everything
backwards i feel really bad and i feel
sad about it
but with despair there is the drive to
make a difference back home i hope in
the future
i changed some
somethings people liked all about
i hope to change them so you don't want
to just
change life here
you want to change life in afghanistan
in the future there is a hope only her
mom khadijah rahimi dreams of their
family giving back to the country that
took them in
yeah i'm very happy to be here that my
kids are here they will have a bright
future and i hope in future they will
make this place even a better place what
do you hope for
at the end of all this
i want peace
i just don't want only peace for my own
family that we are in us i want peace
and security for my afghans who are
there who are left behind
now families are expected to resettle
across the country but the exact
timeline for that is unclear at this
point by the way there have been eight
deliveries so far on base including a
set of twins all are american citizens
dana
new hope for the future nancy thank you
very much